[Music]
welcome back to the Julian podcast happy
Monday
this episode is brought to you by
Squarespace we're gonna build the
website do a Squarespace you have an
amazing platform for you even if you've
never done it before to build a website
whether it's a independent small
business sideline gig your hobby or
anything in between you can build a
website Squarespace go to Squarespace
comm slash annejulien for 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain or
you can do a free trial and see how you
like it also guys the skin get yourself
up to date with what's going on in the
world with a 5 minute readable
newsletter that comes for free to your
email it is so nice go to th es que IMM
comm slash done and Julien it's
completely free you just subscribe and
then you get information at your
fingertips and at your toe tips and
you're also entered when I turn 50 log
Visa gift card when you sign up toe tips
and it can we talk about the fact that
one of the fake man names is a real band
that I came up with good tell us Julian
so I was giving commentary in the
background of one of Gina's videos as I
do and don't make fun of my homemade
haircut and Julian said the homemade
haircut band name called it and then a
few days later I look on Twitter and
there's a band named homemade haircut
homemade haircuts I don't know tweeting
the video of our saying that and saying
thanks for the accidental shoutout and
it's a real band Sparkle I wonder how
many of the band names that you called
are actually real bids well this is the
first one that's owned up to it there's
got to be more that's a great name for a
band
this is homemade here just homemade
haircuts this is lovely lovely then they
can get it flag me homemade haircuts
wait this is really nice this is really
nice honestly homemade haircut they can
get it they can get it go homemade
haircuts Falls a lot of money yet that
one spotify dude they can and they're
really sweet too but how funny is that
like I don't think sometimes I don't
realize that my words actually like go
out into the university and people here
though why because we make them alone in
my kitchen yeah well it feels very like
isolated while we're in there yeah I'm
just shouting things non-stop off-camera
you sometimes laugh you sometimes ignore
me but at the end of the day I ignore
you a lot I would say it's 5050
sometimes when I sit down to edit my
videos I realize just how much you've
said that I don't hear because I'm
trying to concentrate with something
like I'm in the middle of something so
like we'll just be sitting you know like
when you're at home with your partner
your family or whatever and you're
focused on doing something or you're in
another room sometimes yeah I just I
hear all the things that you say that I
like miss in the moment and I'm like
Julia oh my god what is all of this so
you have like a julienne filter to where
like maybe 70% of what I say just goes
through the filter and gets caught and
then when you're editing it's like the
filters off because I'm not in the room
yeah I don't know doing your makeup
sometimes like a lot of times or when
I'm doing like the prosthetics or making
a wig you know I'm like focused on doing
something yeah I'm trying to get
something done yeah that's fair so I
don't always hear it's not just like
banter banter banter I hear everything
it's like a little bit of banter a
little bit of laughing and then I'm like
while we're filming I'm like actually
focused on getting
tasks done you know I mean yeah and that
you know that makes perfect sense to me
because sometimes I'll say something
that I'm like okay this is a banger and
I'm waiting for you to laugh and you
don't laugh I'm like she must not be
paying attention because I'm like trying
to do something no but you I mean it
makes sense like you can have
conversations while you're focused on it
on a task but you can't fully like I
would enjoy everything I've done if I
only absorbed everything that you said
is there a an astrological sign that's
good at that
what like really absorbing information
while also staying focused on time so
that's just like a superhuman I think
that's like a superhuman well so I'm the
type of person like when I was in school
I am NOT I'm a type of person that can
listen to music and I get like while you
study or just in school or while I study
you know like especially while I'm
reading oh yeah yeah I personal even if
there's like no lyrics really I mean
that's ideally the only music I can
listen to if I'm trying to absorb
information or do a task yeah I feel
like I'm really audio sensitive like you
always get so mad at me because I can't
hear the TV and I'm always like I can't
hear it like turning up I can't hear the
dialogue it like really frustrates me
and it's not that I like physically
can't hear it needs to be like at a
point where I can understand it so that
I can absorb it
you don't mean or else I get frustrated
but if I'm reading and there's noises
and there's things happening yeah I feel
like my if I'm trying to concentrate on
something my like sensory everything is
sort of like trained to shut off audio
noises mm-hmm and audio distractions
because I can't focus if I'm listening
so it's sort of like you've evolved like
you you know that your brain absorbs
information or can focus on a task when
you're not taking in sensory information
so when I'm talking yeah and you're
doing your makeup your brain is like
ever Julian's voice shut it off is it's
erroneous yeah it needs to be out of my
brain so I can do what's actually
important
well so like Herman the parts were like
interacting with each other yeah I've I
broken I've broken it I've mentally like
looked at you yeah speaking with you now
I'm talking to you but the times when I
have decided that I'm focusing on
something I will go back and edit and
I'm like I didn't even realize that you
had said anything it's funny because
I'll hear you editing and kind of burst
out laughing at something and I didn't
hear at the first I know and then you'll
show me what it is and I was like yeah
that was a banger like where were you
but it's not because I'm I'm trying to
be insensitive and not listen no I get
it I like preservation I I'm telling you
I would get so upset like I was the
person that would maybe sometimes have
to go to a library or stuff like that in
order to do a paper or read or something
like that III denta fie with not being
able to fully focus on a task especially
reading with any sort of music like I
always envied people in school who would
have their their iPod in their you know
their headphones in their ears and like
they're just reading because I'm like I
have a hard time reading as is without
headphones so like you're just normally
and studying like I remember people you
know in high school know MIT like
middles whatever school they would put
they would wire their iPod cord through
their sweater right here and then they
would put it on their ear and I thought
that was so cool so I remember trying it
I was like I'm I can't pay attention I'm
like so focused on like just getting
this to my ear and then I'm trying to
enjoy the music but then I'm also like
what is my teacher saying what if she
calls on me like what is the point of
this so I I do identify a little bit
with that struggle but maybe not to the
extent I mean cuz you I've seen you you
know when your focus you really do have
to like sense out some things to keep
that focus yeah I get like really I get
really frustrated because I've when I
was in college and in graduate school
look if there was like music or it was
loud I would get angry because I'm like
okay I'm just I'm just gonna try and
study anyways yeah and I would realize
that whatever you know chapter I had
just read I like hadn't fully absorbed
so now I'm frustrated and I'm like now I
have to go back and read it because I
don't fully understand
and everything that is such a shitty
feeling if it's dead quiet then I'm like
okay my brain absorbed it that's why I
feel like if there's like a lot of noise
or like the thing I hate so much as an
adult
is when there's TV playing and music
playing and like others if there's like
multiple audio noises happening to me I
get really overwhelmed I'm like shut one
of them off please I can't function I
will often put my air pods in on
underneath my gaming headset so I could
watch a stream and listen to Netflix at
the same time that is my happy place
I saw Shane post about that or I think
she posted about it she had her ear pods
underneath her gaming headset I was like
dude I do that because I'll be watching
something on my phone with my ear pods
and then I'll go to my computer I'll be
like oh who's streaming and then I'll be
watching a stream and then I'm listening
to both and that's just like I'm fine
that's that's good for me yeah I feel
like there's people that can do that and
then there's people like me that would
make me throw up and it's so boring they
just don't know one thing I can't do I'm
not like a multi listener but I'm not I
mean it's not only just like I'm a it's
not like I'm like I'm absorbing all this
information at once no I'm like I'm
hearing the noise and I'm not
necessarily like fully enjoying it but
it's just like comforting to have all
that stimuli yeah I don't know why um
not for me but when you were talking
about reading and then getting through a
whole chapter me like I don't know what
I just read that was me all the time you
were doing it in a quiet space no I was
I would read a sentence and it would be
like you know in 1940 they really spent
a lot of time building this construction
of the building that ended up being and
I'm like Oh construction I wonder what
that look like and then it would remind
me of a video I watched yesterday or a
movie and I'm like oh that was a dope
scene oh well when does the sequel come
and then I would finish a chapter and
I'd be on this complete tangent of like
my own thought that like took over and
it sucks because I'll be absorbing up
until the point where I tangent and I'm
enjoying the book so I get excited and
then my brain just goes I'm excited
let's think about all this stuff so I
don't read any more
[Laughter]
audiobooks are really good for me well
so it also for me it depends on the task
too but like if I'm doing something that
I find to be like relaxing or I don't
have to actually focus on like if I'm
doing my makeup I can watch youtube
videos I can listen the podcast I can
listen to music okay and all of that's
fine yeah if I'm doing something like if
I was writing you know my radio show or
something where I need to be focused
yeah if there's noises I'm like I start
freaking out because I can't focus
yeah if I need to actually like apply my
brain to it like all the videos that I
make yeah if I'm doing something new
that I've never done you know like I'm
sure I could look but like you where I'm
applying prosthetics or doing the the
green screen stuff or you know I'm the
chair remember how like I was so focused
right in that video I couldn't even move
behind the camera would distract you
there's so much footage of me just
silently like not moving and painting on
my face yeah we like I really had to
focus yeah yeah no I get that you're
applying yourself you need like the
environment to be a certain way so
you're not just like taking out of focus
every two seconds I get that but it's
not that I'm ignoring you no I know that
but speaking of being distracted from
noises I we have this thing where I want
to go to sleep I always go to sleep
before you like I fall asleep before you
but I'll turn on whatever show we're
going to sleep to and I'll like click
click click click so it's like two
volume or something so it's like very
faint but it's like loud enough to where
you can hear it's comforting and then
Jenna will come in and be like I'm gonna
turn on a documentary were a serious
reads about serial killers really loud
and puts it up like 20 volume and then
I'll wake up in the middle the night and
in like a cold sweat out of a nightmare
from this Siri voice like a literal
robot voice reading monotone about how
many guys this person is killed I'm like
Jenna what is what what is happening why
is it so loud and I look over and you're
not you're like completely fine and
asleep think what the heck
what is that how do you go to sleep with
loud how do you focus on sleep with loud
stimuli yes see that's weird to me like
you first of all you're only sensitive
to the sound of the TV right in the two
and a half minutes it takes you to fall
asleep and then we vary it's a crucial
time period that you you wake up in the
middle of the night sometimes would you
I don't do yeah I like if I'm asleep
you're not waking up yeah
you wake up like multiple times yes in
the night yeah so it's only important to
you because Julian will say can you turn
that down I can't possibly and I'm like
you're gonna be asleep in like two
minutes
and I'm gonna turn it back up and you're
never even gonna be able to tell I can't
hear I can't hear them I'm like I'm not
ready to sleep yet I'm not tired
I'm trying to watch this I can't watch
it if I can't hear it background TV no
I'm watching something okay I can't
watch background TV I it's like when you
go to a nail salon and they have like
Frazier playing in the background but
like you can't tell what's happening and
I'm like I'm so frustrated I wish I
could just hear it but that's part of
the fun no yeah I know it is it's not
it's part of the fun it's relaxing it's
white it white noise
no it's white noise no some people watch
streams like that
I'll get people coming in chat being
like hey like I just finished like three
hours of studying and I didn't even know
what's going on but I had you guys on
the whole time yeah thanks for being my
background and I'm like I'm happy to be
that cuz I I can't have that background
noise was studying I wouldn't be able to
have a twitch stream in the background
oh if I was doing my makeup I'd be able
to have a Twitter stream there's like
different tasks that have different
limits for me like studying and reading
I probably couldn't either but drawing
and yeah maybe like prepping things or
doing something physical around the
house cleaning whatever I can totally
have a lot of I love I thrive on that
mhm you know walking the dog so I'll pop
in my headphones yeah if I'm in bed and
I want to watch something that's not
white noise I'm trying to listen to
something
that's wine downtime no it's not focused
on a new subject its get ready I feel
like I like to watch things that really
blow my mind at night why so then I go
to bed and I have crazy dreams you do
love it 10 out of 10
what kind of dreams have you had
recently like those I don't I haven't
been keeping track so I wake up and I
forget them but they've been crazy not
crazy but I feel like I have better
dreams when I watch like ancient aliens
then if I didn't fair or like membre
used to watch a lot of like Dateline or
a lot of documentaries yeah I used to
get bad dreams from watching Breaking
Bad before bed yeah too close I don't
get bad dreams like after watching
something like that do you really have
nightmares do you no not really
I have nightmares I used to have a lot
of nightmares like what in a time of my
life when I was very very stressed out
mm-hmm
no I totally have identified that exact
correlation mm-hmm by micellar in my
life too and sometimes it'll pop up like
I'll go through something in my life and
I'll be stressed out without realizing
it and then I'll just have bad dream
after bad dream after bedroom like okay
I'm stressed out ya know when I was
right when I was really like very
stressed out I would have dreams that I
was drowning constantly which is
horrible oh yeah yeah and sometimes I'll
he'll be having a bad dream and I'll
wake up to a talking head on ancient
aliens and I'm like what are they doing
here it's great you know what I have
done is I've woken up and watched full
entire episodes of stuff that you've
watched like while you want to sleep
I'll wake up and I'll be so awake that
I'll stay up for an entire episode of
whatever it was ancient aliens Seinfeld
a good thing you can hear it I took
you know what there's you know there
should be there's okay
you know how there's sleep timers on TVs
there should be volume timers so you're
like okay in 30 minutes I want the
volume to be at one and we'll start it
at 20 and so by the time you fall asleep
hate that what do you mean I would hate
that because I would be watching it so
make it an hour
it's like aging your bit you're you're
you're hearing just get slowly worse but
for me it'll be perfect
like sleep timers I love those as a kid
when we found out sleep timers exist on
TVs I would set a sleep timer for like
an hour I would go to sleep with the TV
on and then I'll be able to sleep
through the night because it was off
once I was asleep as someone that has a
hard time falling asleep and doesn't
fall asleep in two minutes
I hate sleep timers because I'll be
watching something you're trying to
relax and then it just shuts off and I'm
like [ __ ] yeah that I've had that happen
a sleep timer go off and you're not
asleep that feels very alone that's not
a good feeling how do we get here people
have by the way we need um we need to
get marbles a green pillow because
people want him to be floating I don't
know it won't really look like he's
floating though no I won't it's gonna
look bunk we can we could mount a little
shelf right here
I'm not putting marble on the show or we
could put a little nightstand and cover
it in green-screen
that's possible and then we just set
them on there and then he'll just be
like floating in space probably even go
to outer space everyone wants to see you
float on the table yeah they just want
to see you thrive kid that cool with you
bud
this morning when I think bunny finally
has like a full hold of our schedule
because this morning is as soon as we
woke up she walked straight over to the
podcast room in the door shut and she
started wagging her tail like she wants
to go in there like she knows what day
it is she is a better grasp on what day
of the week it is than I do I was like
how do you know that that's today I
don't know but I just like straight
she doesn't she all week she didn't come
to this door no and then today she did
she just as soon as he woke up and what
like let her out of the bedroom she
walked straight over the podcast Herman
was like okay I go in here today I go in
here today I go in here now this is for
me I want to sit in that little bed that
is for me I sit in there today today
today's the day where I said in there
today I said I'm so [ __ ] obsessed
with that dog it's not even funny
she's funny what are you doing over
there
oh she's thinking about Squarespace and
how they have 24 hours a day 7 days a
week customer support when you're
building a website it's actually super
helpful because a lot of people you have
questions you want to customize certain
things with different colors and panels
and features on your website but you
don't know how to do it no I hate mr.
Squarespace or mrs. Squarespace can you
teach me how to do this and they're like
yes here you go
and that's gonna be at 3 a.m. there you
go here you go here's your website there
you go where is that from Julian by the
way yeah you want me to tell you where
that's from
yes not gonna make any sense okay I
don't know you always say it's why I've
exaggerated I'm a parrot I've
exaggerated I've exaggerated it we're
interrupting the sponsor read but I've
exaggerated it so I say here you go like
I talk like a little bit of a caveman
who you you know yeah but it comes from
an episode of Parks and Rec where Andy
took Andy Dwyer which is Chris Pratt's
character he's big dummy he's in this
office of one of the city councilman's
who's actually the same actor as the the
guy in NHL the the one who what's his
name the most recent commander of hers
what's his name
commander Lawrence commander Lawrence
same actor in Parks and Rec
why are you mocking me why are you
thinking funny why are you doing that
for
why are you doing it for God anyways we
had a sponsor we did they left they left
sorry Squarespace alright guys build a
website now go do it
seriously Squarespace is really awesome
they have 24/7 customer support live
webinars okay you want to add something
to your website they make it very easy
impossible to do it you can design your
website exactly how you want let's say
you're getting married and you want to
create a website for your family and
friends to know about it with the
pictures and the information and
everything they can make it so easy to
edit and manage exactly what you want
simple easy and beautiful okay so go to
Squarespace comm / 10 and Julian try a
free trial if you'd like or you can get
10% on four website or domain with your
first purchase when you use that URL is
an awesome service highly recommend
check it out and then when you build
your website tweeted at us we like to
look at your websites also guys the skin
seven million people currently wake up
to the skin newsletter in their email it
is very useful it is a nice tool
especially in today's day and age
literally information is everything and
you just want some straight-up facts
given to you and a nice concise easy to
read and digest format
coffee and the skin will make you
smarter it's proven okay so go to th es
que IMM com / turn on Julian
okay and deep dive into some of their
easy digests as well as their
newsletters that come in every day they
have different sections they have it's
it's honestly really great like if you
haven't tried it even just try it to see
how they lay it out it's really cool
who ever like created the format for it
is really smart because it's it's
creative and fun but it's simple enough
to not have to like think about it so
check it out th es que I mmm two M's com
/ annejulien
sign up for free it's completely free
and you're entered to win a chance that
if these twenty dollar Visa gift card
thank you sponsors thanks for putting up
with us wait so he just hold on : stop
mocking me okay the actor who plays
commander Lawrence is in Parks and Rec
in this scene we literally finished
Handmaid's Tale last night so we're like
super fresh in our brain great show by
the way
he's the city councilman and he what he
one of his hobbies is he bailed ships in
bottles you've seen them like the model
ships that go inside bottles so he has
them all over his office yeah
so Andy while they're having a meeting
is like you know monkeying it and he
goes I did it I got it out he's like
you're not supposed to take it out of
the bottle and then he's like here you
go that's where I got it no it's very
dumb but it's like that's kind of the
vibe that I've been trying to give off
that you're handing someone a ship in a
bottle but just the ship part that
you've taken out of that they've spent
many hours putting in or however that
works I don't got it good are you good
to go yeah are you sick mmm I'm sick
sick my god I'm sick mate why are you
doing that for
what are you doing that for speaking of
that see I'm a parrot I can't stop we've
already we've already established this
well I want to say on the podcast can i
plug my my tattoo goal okay the charity
one yeah okay so we did a charity stream
for Australia because of all the
horrible bush fires that are going on
where we donated so the RSPCA of New
South Wales donated about eight point
five thousand dollars u.s. dollars
twelve thousand five s eight point five
thousand eight and a half thousand and
our goal is to continue every stream
from now until we hit twenty five
thousand dollars raised which is every
bit of money we make on stream with subs
research donations bits will go towards
the RSPCA and I told chat and I want to
tell you guys that at twenty five
thousand dollars I will get a tattoo for
an Australia themed tattoo to celebrate
reaching twenty five thousand dollars
raised so if you guys feel like watching
me get a tattoo
come donate and support the stream and
the tattoo will be designed by one of
you guys because we have a little thing
in our discord group join the discord
there's a tattoo for charity group and
you can put your submissions right in
there and all the best one will win so
well hopefully the best one is just a
word that says now and a you are now
yeah Rome said she would be down if I
got her face tattooed on me
oh dude like what cause Lexy was like
then she say you should get a tattoo of
Rome on Twitter you see that was like
yeah we're [ __ ] talk okay that would
be so sick
like a super hyper realistic portrait of
Rome hyper realistic portrait of Rome
with like a sparkling Australian flag in
the back and then underneath it is just
said now no it's her fist and then it
says na you are on her face now and then
under it it said North murder but like
Kay and so your family no no I thank you
for that I'm so sorry we're not trying
to offend anyone with our horrible
Australian science noise murder I'm
trying to you say you're not trying to
offend someone and then you do that I'm
sorry
that's what if dogs barked in Australian
accents I don't know are we tired maybe
rawr that was that shouldn't have come
out of my mouth
so you're really actually gonna get it
like it is gonna be where's it gonna go
I'm leaving it up to the dink fam you
guys it'll depend you know I think back
peace no not an entire back piece but I
think we'll get the top four submissions
and I'll let everyone choose and between
them and then we can all just decide
where it's gonna go on my body I have a
lot of real estate so we can put it
wherever wherever wall we're putting it
wherever yeah not on my ass though cuz
I'm not gonna take a picture of my butt
Wow
although this is a classic ass tattoo
situation right like in the office where
he promises an ass tattoo for however
many thousand combined points for
productivity and then they all kick
their ass into gear and he gets a nice
tattoo
Andy that is Andy Wow
what an office beast no no no no no no
no it's no no don't do that
why not okay fine do it
[Music]
nari
I'm excited to see your tattoo mm-hmm
and I hope that you reach that goal
because that is a very worthy cause yeah
it would be cool to reach that goal for
sure
where you going dog why are you
following is he drunk no he's just
getting up to stretch his legs let him
live hey hey everything's fine okay
I know gravity gravity is complicated
little old man we were walking bunny one
time we'll end a couple of the littles I
think over by that bike path that we
like to take her like right when we got
her mm-hmm and we met a guy on the
street that was telling us about how his
littlest dog just went blind and he was
like yeah it just happens like overnight
literally like it was just a no it's
just a little dog you know so now I'm
terrified that one of them's just gonna
go blind over her and they're gonna wait
it's gonna be first Oh gonna get you a
muffins hallo boy muffins hallo the
little it's like a basketball hoop that
goes over their head one of the funniest
most adorable inventions I've ever seen
but Jenna no I'm scared I'm just gonna
wake up and I'm like can you see today
well he's I mean to think that someone
went through that where it's like cuz
obviously you would think like if your
dog goes blind it would be a slow and
very clear process I had no idea no pun
intended but yeah overnight it's scary
that's crazy but you know I I also don't
think their life would really change all
that much I mean he is a sight hound and
he loves chasing squirrels and whatever
but he you know they they're lazy
there'll be on the couch more sometime
anyway well yeah he would just use his
sense of smell to smell where I am so
that he could know which direction to
cry
that survival instinct that's his only
survival instinct right now well I mean
they walk on leashes so they don't
really need to see well he Kermit
honestly the like they are sighthounds
yeah they want to see the squirrels and
stuff do they enjoy going for visually
stimulating walks but I
he loves to smell other dogs pee like
that's what he lives for
you know if he couldn't see he would
have just as good a time cuz he'd be
smelling the pee pees yeah as long as he
got that tongue to lick with he's just
he can be nasty everywhere he wants God
putting it back in your mouth it's gonna
dry out my guy ever since that guy told
me that though every day I'm like oh my
god when's it gonna happen what if it
just happens overnight and I just wake
up in you're blind what if it happens on
his birthday Oh buddy pork I remember we
forgot your birthday that was funny
we've okay we didn't forget it we forgot
it and then remembered it at the end of
the day yeah that's that sucks
that's like sixteen Candles I'm sorry
bud oh it's okay we don't play quick
game yeah I do so this is a game this
game I develop are called real or fake
Jiu Jitsu position Jenna guesses that's
a bad name I own you know like a couple
so this is a game I developed where we
were talking about jujitsu positions or
something to where I said something and
she was like is that a real is that a
real jujitsu move or did you just make
it up and I thought that'd be funny I
could get a list of real moves and
techniques in jujitsu and then pair them
up with a bunch of fake ones and see if
she can tell the difference which one's
real which one's fake I'm ready so how
should I do this should I just read one
you guys have it's real or fake or do I
read if I don't know you tell me okay
how about this I I have them all with
counterparts so I have a real one next
to a fake one that's similar so I could
read one a real or one fake and then you
guess if it's really fake and then I
read the counterpart does that make
sense
okay just guess don't like me I was
liking you naptime
what the hell naptime is that real or is
it fake fake I feel like that's fake
because that's like slang that you call
when you choke somebody that's fake I
made that up good that's not a taut
technique bulldog choke definitely 100%
real
that is real yeah good for you thank you
well done it's similar to what bunny did
to you where she put her head right here
except if you were to just mm-hmm
just like a straight-up little
schoolyard choke yeah
sit up guard sit up guard sit up guard
so I'm imagining that that means maybe
you're okay I don't think that it's real
first of all but if it was it would be
like you're on your back and you're in a
guard that's in the position of like a
sit-up
I think it's fake it's real oh it's like
if you were to but scoot around mmm
that's setup guard what oh so you know
what it looks like what someone but
scoots crab are they playing crab soccer
not crab soccer grab soccer I could have
gone pro I might if I had stuck with it
I could have been a pro grabs ugly I'm
gonna proceed now kitty roll cotton
candy sweet well let me see your Katie
rope Katie ball cancer is it real or
fake now is the part where they're
starting to get weird uh I guess it's
real no it's fake kitty roll yeah I
don't know maybe like fun
meow the whole time finger trap ill real
fake what what if it's like a mole bring
it you know you can have wrist control
you you like you can't carrot mouth yeah
hit manipulate someone's finger
Margot I don't understand the rules
bow and arrow Chuck that one's real
you've done that one to me it hurts
nice inverted spider I know that spiders
a real thing
so I imagine inverted spiders probably
real inverted spider good job for the
spider guard deep half guard that sounds
like something oh that is deep in there
I don't have guards real so I don't
understand why you can't that's that's
just an adjective
deep half guard half guards real deep
half guard no it's real so that just
means that you're farther into half
guard well it's an exaggerated half
guard so where you dive under a person's
legs really Superman takedown is that
when you just like run at them as fast
as you can into their stomach no you
don't go like this no no that's how you
injure yourself
yeah that's tackling that one yeah okay
I'd say it's fake say the lasso let's
see that uh it just sounds like you're
taking someone else's belt or like
someone else's shirt collar and like
hooking it around their neck I'd say
it's real because y'all are sick Casso
is real yes not that at all what is it
you take your leg oh okay why are you
making up noise but I haven't even
described it's going on so bad and I
just every time you say something I just
think of all the physical pain you take
your leg okay so say I have your wrist
like this mm-hmm I would take my leg
over the top this is my leg okay over
the top of your arm and tuck it oh don't
like it and it lasses your arm so that I
have control this arm especially when I
have this grip right here what's going
on all right
the DMV that's fake oh yeah that's fake
first-class iron bar
okay armbars real thing i know there's
many types of arm bars mm-hmm
first-class arm bar I would say it's
fake it is fake
back to back joke boy back to that check
is that when you guys are back to back
and then you put your hands behind you
and you you go like this with your hands
and you just choke them as hard as you
can into your head and back fake okay
let's take ready gogoplata
that's real oh [ __ ] how'd you know that
cuz I've heard that because you found
that it sounds like go-gurt it does
sound like ogre that's all good plug
honey choke someone with your shinbone
I want to die yeah that's horrible Shin
goes right here and you just pull their
head down oh it's really fun actually
okay ready turtle that's real how did
you know that Dan you'd be paying
attention see if you're speaking to me I
can listen to you and I can hear you but
if I were doing something and you were
telling me all of these things I would
never know what you're talking about
soap choke oh my god wait do you choke
someone with soap is it cuz you you drop
soap and no no it's time to choke don't
drop the soap time to choke subject I
will say it's fake you think it's fake
that is fake you're doing really well
the Swiffer sweep I feel like that's not
an actual name but people call it that
so I would say real fake Swiffer sweep
yeah no you know what a sweep is though
yeah that was that was fake top-mount
real yeah it's when you're on top and
mount mm-hmm don't cross your hi Sophie
marble really wants to give you a kiss
hi okay ready yeah
Ezekiel choke that's real how did you
know that because have I told you about
these
I watch a lot of fighting Julian that's
true that's true you've watched a lot of
UFC in your day a lot a lot of them
everything this is not going as well I
mean you're doing well that's cool
highlight crucifix that's real that is
real thank you Star of David that is
that is not no that's fake Julian the
pizza pass I don't think that's real
that's fake
electric chair like I think that's fake
it's real what is it electric chair it's
a real thing but is it a jujitsu thing
it is a real jujitsu person what is it
well I could show you it might be easier
absolutely not no show it to someone
else
no no I'll show it to you it's not it's
probably the least painful thing that's
what you always say
no this one's very painful by comparison
to choking someone with your shin I'm
still not interested are you ready for
this one yes fetish foot lock Julian
fake I know a heel hook is real but a
fetish foot lock can get out of here
fetish foot lock band name called it
straight for luck probably real real
Casey Khatami I don't know I'd say real
it is real mm-hmm it's a side control
position I is I love you so much but I
don't think you could come up with a
word like that that was fake tackle my
intelligence no not at all I feel like
my telogen has been attacked play dead
real fake okay that's what I would do
how would they teach that because you're
being a possum Cup control oh it sounds
illegal you can't do that fake fake
so I said Kasich Khatami right okay so
Khatami fake that's fake
that's just cheese in Spanish butterfly
guard real what is it it's when your
legs are like this and someone's on top
of you it's actually pretty accurate
thank you just when you're in the
instead
of your foot is inside there keep the
hair thigh twister fake no it's real
okay that actually might be one of the
most painful submissions tell us it's
when you have sort of like a 45 degree
back control and instead of choking them
you are turning their head
you're just baby it's basically a neck
crank it's really painful that's
horrible and it's you're like twisting
their head away from the way their
bodies being turned I'm gonna throw up
so you're twisting them like you would
wring out a paper towel or a regular
towel so like a full body rope burn with
you're literally a full body rope burn
huh
it's happened in the UFC it's [ __ ] a
gnarly that's horrible switchblade choke
that's real that is real really good
choke only really able to do it with
biggie though yeah that's why I get
choked knee on belly that's real you've
done it to me I hated it how do you
spell that
what how do you spell it how do you
spell it okay and EE no n EO n belly
knee on belly no its knee on belly well
then you past weird test the bird he
keeps killing you uh I don't think
that's real no let's fake that's nyan
neck oh it's not called me on neck me on
neck fake fire fire choke fake fake
that's Toshi roll like shrimp hip escape
Toshiro is this like some slang that you
used for warm-up what do you think I'm
doing when I go to fake its fake bicep
slicer real what is that that's pretty
accurate it's a really thick it's real
it's real most gyms don't actually allow
it that's terrible it can blow your knee
ah I'm gonna throw up Peruvian necktie
that's real really uh-huh how'd you knew
that
what is it I can demonstrate on peach
isn't it when they take you take
someone's own like GE jacket and you're
choking them with it but no no that's a
good guess that's that's like a Bravo
detail choke that's sort of like
switchblade I've shown that one to you
but the Peruvian necktie has actually
been done in the UFC because you don't
need to give for it right but it's it
looks like they're setting up a
guillotine where they're they're holding
someone's head like this except the
person who's being chokes head is go
goes underneath the person who's choking
legs so and then they sit back and they
lean to the side so it's like a
guillotine but they've stuffed their
head down 45-degree angle it's called
the Peruvian oh I don't like that I
don't want it to happen to me it's it's
a pretty gnarly choke I don't want it to
happen to me I think that's all the ones
I have well you did good I think I think
I think you got like 90% of them no no
you did I don't think you missed that
many I mean you called my [ __ ]
pretty much every time so congrats on
knowing how to call me thank you
I tried my very best next week we're
gonna remove the table and I'm just
gonna demonstrate everything I just said
not on me not on me you better bring a
friend I'm Jenna you better bring a
friend you gonna do part 5 no I don't I
do not it's not the sport for super fun
I love it I respect it and I really like
the culture of sport I love how nice and
respectful everyone is of each other I
just think it's a wonderful thing it is
just not for me I do not want it for you
not it's not for me it's not for me
it's not for me it is for you no it's
not yeah it's for you no it is yeah no
yeah no okay
couples who share their interests but
it's all dry Kermit we're gonna get
popped for like cop like we're gonna get
age restricted because that's so
disgusting
we're gonna need a a warning on our
video you're gonna restrict our video to
only
because that's gross put it back in wait
till he does it you put your tongue back
in your mouth honey it's gonna get all
dried out anyway thank you guys for
hanging out and listening to us talk for
a podcast it's pretty cool that we get
to do that I'm glad you guys hang out
and I enjoy it um see you guys next week
marble you got anything left you got
anything we'll get you a green pillow
marble green pillow will make you flow
in space okay well just cover this in
green we could just cover this in green
yeah
we have green fabric right redo we have
green screen fabric see how you look Bob
she's sitting in that ear so far they
want you to be on like a flying magic
carpet Bobby
yeah tapia fun video he's he's being
real hammy today he really wants you to
kiss him and pet him
you're gonna give us a struggle noise
wait why are you bouncing him he'll just
make it thank you
good boy well you guys have a great week
we'll be streaming on Twitch throughout
the week come support if you wanted to
donate to Australia and we'll see you
guys next week on the podcast thank you
for hanging we love you guys bye
[Music]
[Music]